so you're like a leaf floating down the
river
you just have to accept that there's a
river and you just
float you don't have a ruler the thing
is that the illusion that you are an
agent is a construct right what part of
that is actually under your control
and i think that our consciousness is
largely a control model for our own
attention so we
notice where we are looking and we can
influence what we are looking how we are
disambiguating things how we put things
together in our mind
and the whole system that runs us is
this big cybernetic motivational system
so we're basically like a little monkey
sitting on top of an elephant and we can
put this elephant here and there to go
this way or that way and we might have
the illusion that we are the elephant or
that we are telling it what to do and
sometimes we notice that it walks into a
completely different direction and we
didn't set this thing up it just is the
situation that we find ourselves in
how much prodding can we actually do of
the elephant
a lot
but uh
i think that our uh consciousness cannot
create the motive force
is the elephant consciousness in this
metaphor no the monkey
is the consciousness the monkey is the
attentional system that is observing
things there is a large perceptual
system combined with the motivational
system that is actually providing the
interface to everything and our own
consciousness i think is a tool that
directs the attention of that system
which means it singles out features
and uh performs conditional operations
for which it needs an index memory but
this index memory is what we perceive as
our stream of consciousness but the
consciousness is not in charge that's an
illusion so everything
outside of that consciousness
is the elephant so it's the physics of
the universe but it's also society
that's outside of your i would say the
elephant is the agent so there is an
environment which the agent is stomping
and uh you are influencing a little part
of that agent
so uh can you is the agent a single
human being
what's what which object has agency
that's an interesting question i think a
way to think about an agent is that it's
a controller with a setpoint generator
the notion of a controller comes from
cybernetics and control theory control
system consists out of a system that is
regulating uh some value
and the deviation of that value from a
set point and it has a sensor that
measures the system's deviation from
that set point
and an effector that can be
parameterized by the controller so the
controller tells the effector to do a
certain thing and the goal is to reduce
the distance between the set point and
the current value of the system and
there's environment which disturbs the
regulated system which brings it away
from that set point so simplest case is
the thermostat the thermostat is really
simple because it doesn't have a model
the thermostat is only trying to
minimize the set point deviation in the
next moment
and if you want to minimize the set
point deviation over a longer time span
you need to integrate it you need to
model what is going to happen so for
instance when you think about uh that
your set point is to be comfortable in
life
maybe you need to make yourself
uncomfortable first
right so you need to make a model of
what's going to happen when and this is
task of the controller is to use its
sensors to measure the state of the
environment and the system that is being
regulated and figure out what to do
and if the task is complex enough the
set points are complicated enough and if
the controller has enough capacity and
enough
sensor feedback then the task of the
controller is to make a model of the
entire universe that it's in the
conditions under which it exists and of
itself
and this is a very complex agent and we
are in that category
and
an agent is not necessarily a thing in
the universe it's a class of models that
we use to interpret aspects of the
universe
and
be when we notice the
around us a lot of things only make
sense at the level that you are
entangled with them if we interpret them
as control systems that make models of
the world and try to minimize their own
set points so but the models
are the agents
the agent is a class of model
and we notice that we are an agent
ourself we are the agent that is using
our own control model to perform actions
we notice we
produce a change in the model and things
in the world change and this is how we
discover
the idea that we have a body that we are
situated environment and that really
have a first-person perspective
still don't understand
what's the best way to think of which
object has agency with with respect to
human beings
is is it the body
is it the brain
is it the contents of the brain that has
agency like what's the actuators that
you're referring to what is the
controller and where does it reside or
is it these impossible things like
because i keep trying to ground it to
space-time
the three-dimensional space
and the one dimension of time
what's the agent in that for humans
there is not just one it depends on the
way in which you're looking at this
thing in which you are framing it
imagine that you are
say angela merkel and you are acting on
behalf of germany
then you could say that germany is the
agent and in the mind of angela merkel
she is germany to some extent because in
the way in which she acts the destiny of
germany changes
there are things that she can change
that basically
affect the behavior of that nation state
okay so it's hierarchies of to go to
another one of your tweets
with uh i think you're uh
playfully mocking jeff hawkins
with saying his brains all the way down
so it's like it's agents all the way
down
it's agents made up of agents made up of
agents like if andrew merkel is germany
and germany's made up a bunch of people
and the people are themselves agents
in in some kind of context
and then people are made up of cells
each individual
so is it agents all the way down
i suspect that has to be like this in a
world where things are self-organizing
most of the complexity that we are
looking at
everything in life is about
self-organization yeah so i think up
from the level of
life you have
agents
and
below life you rarely have agents
because
sometimes you have control systems that
emerge randomly in nature and try to
achieve a set point but
they're not that interesting agents that
make models and because to make an
interesting model of the world you
typically need a system that is during
complete
you